erbium yeah so this is another one with
an unusual ones is it a lanthorn I TSO
lanthanide isn't it erbium erbium is a a
photographic filter and it is actually a
nuclear poison what that means is that
it will kill dead any nuclear fission
process so its ghostly got some
applications there it's an interesting
element when you make compounds of it
and dissolve it in solution it's often
pink so this is some erbium trichloride
now you'll notice it's very slightly
pink a lot of the lanthanides have very
weak but interesting colors in solution
and pink is obviously one of them I
think this is one of the ones which
because of its pink color motion gets
used in jewelry and things like
sunglasses and things like life memory
serves so here you see erbium ok so this
is one of those unusual metals from the
bottom of the periodic table again but
it's stored in a glass ampule under an
inert atmosphere of argon so the argon
is really unreactive it helps us
preserve and save the metal so that we
can carry out interesting reactions so
here's erbium really quite beautiful
shiny metal wonderful sample well as you
see here that the formula was just
erbium trichloride if I just sprinkled
this out on the bench then moisture from
the air would end up coordinating and
for every erbium you'd end up with about
six or seven water molecules
co-ordinators which is a problem if you
want to do any air sensitive or moisture
sensitive chemistry because those water
molecules are other coordinate to the
erbium as soon as anything comes into
proximity with them they'll react so you
have to have it moisture three